Also, please follow the discussions taking
place respectfully on The David Pakman Show
sub Reddit at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.
That's all Reddit more than more than 26000.
Can you imagine more than 20?
These are numbers no one's ever seen before.
More than 26000 of our viewers and listeners
participating in the discussion.
One user suggests I was checking out some
of the discussions this morning.
One of our viewers says, I think there's a
95 percent chance Republicans will try to
impeach Biden on day one, going on to say,
honestly, I'm not even being facetious.
I think they'll start bringing forward articles
of impeachment the minute Biden is sworn in.
We all know what's the first thing they're
going to try to impeach him for.
They will argue Biden is an illegitimate president
due to mass voter fraud and election rigging
in the twenty twenty presidential election.
They might also cite Ukraine scandals being
unfit for office or cognitive impairment or
make up a corruption story.
I, I don't expect impeachment articles to
be filed against Biden right away.
But I would certainly I mean, listen, this
is one of the most weaponized Republican parties
we've we've seen as long as I've been following
politics closely, which I would say at this
point is about, you know, 20 years.
This is one of the most weaponized Republican
Party.
So I wouldn't be surprised at some point to
see an attempt at impeaching Joe Biden.
And again, this is why Democrats have control
of the House and control of the Senate is
in question based on the January 5th Senate
runoffs in Georgia.
If Democrats control the House and the Senate,
it puts these fears essentially to bed.
Another post from The David Pakman Show sub
Reddit, which is not as convinced that the
December 14th elector vote is the end, saying
it should be over with the electors having
voted.
But Trump supporters, among them elected officials,
are holding their delusions close and vowing
to disrupt the certification of ballots on
January 6th.
Even after that, the inauguration could be
targeted.
I keep wanting to celebrate and see us moving
on, but unlike the Trump lists, I see the
clear reality that we are not out of the woods
and more insane, even violent actions are
still a possibility.
Sorry to say I actually am.
I'm less worried about a disruption on January
six.
I assume that some Republican members of the
House will stand and object when certain state
electoral votes, electoral votes are being
counted.
Maybe even some members of the Senate will
stand and say, Mr. Speaker or whoever, you
know, Mr. Senate president, which is going
to be Mike Pence at the time.
I object, but I don't think that's going to
go anywhere.
The violence does concern me more because
at any point there is a tinderbox situation
here.
If Trump says the wrong thing or the right
thing, depending on your perspective, I think
the sycophants are ready to go absolutely
crazy, claiming they are defending who the
person they believe to be that they see as
the rightful winner of the twenty twenty election.
So that worries me more than any serious disruption
to the process on January 6th.
Let me know if you disagree and join the discussion
at David Pakman dotcom slash.
Read it.